it's so hard to grieve when you have to
keep up a social profile you need these
big breaks and sometimes you need breaks
bigger than YouTube will allow you to
have otherwise your channel dies like
[__] me I need to pay the rent but I
also need to keep my mind sane unknown
as this guy that critiques people and
takes the piss and stuff it's not
necessarily how I want to be known I'm
good at it I am emotional I do have more
to me than just [__] slagging things
up like the with any face the famous
will an easy that everyone brings up I
didn't feel that you were in a good
space then right and you took it the
wrong way
yes of how you were feeling in general I
should have always taken that as a joke
I like always
you were like heavily critical obviously
yeah the YouTube box and things have you
ended up going into a [__] boxing gym
all of a sudden I can't box right I do
not know what I'm doing but every single
day training I'm eating well I'm so much
happier and I think [__] this is what
these youtubers have in there what's he
dressed in
I don't understand oh right Wow Wow just
this is so can I just say this happens
on this all the time right record enough
I'm the only YouTube oh does not know
how to work these on iphone coverage
you're like this it's true I'd say you
look like a Georgia Farion hmm yeah I'll
be recording that's true Mali will be
rolling I love the big entrance I'll put
it on a thought they're gonna make
comments I've got a minute I like I'm
with the two more six sarcastic folks
yeah on YouTube cons as well it's not in
my nature to judge t-shirts yeah no not
not like not in front of the youtuber
anywhere
yeah you're great on YouTube mate ladies
and gentlemen welcome to the true jadi
podcast a third one with my mate
Chuck me to the hat trick you've got the
hot room it wasn't us
that's prestigious isn't that only a few
people have done that like showing up
would Wells done it but I mean he's on X
or so tell three he's on every other way
yeah to be fair Karl's probably on
number five no a plying with drink and
drugs every time you turn to us or to
refer thing is that paracetamol sign X
yeah yeah but uh yeah it's good savvy
it's good to be back this is a lovely
space thank really nice
see you thought he did the bomb shelter
with us so he knows how far it and you
also did the other one the first one so
that the one that was in the actual
recording was a little cactus that's not
my nickname for my penis it's funny
sorry
anyway I was going to talk about dog
Trump's penis then but I thought I was a
little older I don't need to be doing
that though ring ourselves in it's fair
to say that you have had just jump
straight in there with me I was gonna
talk about the t-shirt first I thought
emojis so actually well there's been a
lot of talk about my fashion sense since
I wore what some people said look like a
McDonald's shirt on me last video the
orange stripes or sorry
Tumkur I'm sort of stitches of it sort
of annoyed because I liked it I don't
give a [__] and I've had a lot of
messages some off even women saying it
was nice so Olly Murs wearing the same
thing really yeah it's definitely [__]
you've just that's it no I mean I was
able to convince myself until this point
never has anyone gone I saw they were
commiserating the same thing in gun
musket more yeah the thing only misses a
funny Tommy have you done a video with
him I think you have and he did he seems
like a nice guy but I hate his music
with a fire Java there I've [__] hear
it saw just basically his voice no but
his voice is not it's nothing special is
it it's so if I am it was sold that many
records I'm always like how we consume
in this but it's just catchy shy that's
all it is words words words words he's
one of those nice guys doll for me and
them in the media the way it's like he's
the Jack Whitehall of music like he's
just so nice and he's everywhere and I
just chappie he's really [__] nice we
did this thing where we like swapped
phones to tweet like yeah that for a
while there wasn't there like swapping
phones of the celebrity or like letting
them reads that way 2016 I didn't 2017
yeah but early on these trends and I was
like asking his agent manager whoever
like Kelly tweet this doesn't matter was
just tweeting like the most yeah didn't
care he was doing it because you'd had a
song with that blonde girl who were an
x-factor who was a West Ham fun yeah cuz
one of the questions I asked him was
would you rather shag marry kill she was
one of the Louisa that's the one baby
Redknapp's wife there was two other ones
it'll not someone else MIT all right he
was on tour with Louisa at the time his
I'd shag her pretty much Sherlock and
say that to be fair right
so she did it they also did a video of
will and what she was if she was in the
apartment she must have been don't get
something I screamed shied it and said
it the will and I was like missed
opportunity I mean I told you nothing do
you see it do you every time an arse
appears you sort of see it as a missed
opportunity genuinely show you was
[__] bugger well the thing was I'll be
committed
can we just bring up a picture every
time in our suppose no honestly just a
big blur yeah and he just well there it
is I'm Franco embryos Wacom Oh
mr. Pitts often also also want to look
Louisa Johnson is her name
people often say you know white people
have no culture she is very very choice
and us do much up but she did a porno
you know but it wasn't like one of those
cleverly planned pornos for Purim or
where she like [__] another celebrity
it was just he looked like the most
basic sort of dude from the sort of the
pub when opposed always half as the
caliber of men will change things so
that's why it was such a like
disappointment anyway like it wasn't on
that Kim K sort of every position well
thought out and that as if they were had
a director in the room was just like
shocking yeah I mean the call if
anything on the one hand it made us
think available doable
maybe show me on the other hand I
expected better right very close and I'm
supposed to no one ever thought that
they'd ever hear you say of a woman I
expect it better
do you know what I mean no but it just
looked so uh I mean that cuz you're a
bit of a connoisseur no I really are
watched too much listen did you were you
quite a porn fiend any time in your life
yeah turn things around we're bringing a
body it's funny though cuz we ask these
same questions and dizzy but he asked
them to be cut out so we I thought after
the subscribers you've gained recently
this is gonna be a more highbrow chair
definitely not do you wank if anything
or anything now we've got more views I
know we can keep going further down less
yeah yeah yeah Brian who's Amal yeah
exactly yeah yeah we did us this of
chaos I like what's your favorite porn
sort of thing he's make some shots right
if you're wondering [__] shots gun shots
assisting well I guess that's the
moneymaker isn't it but I'm not I'm not
that asked I was never ever until SB
important Ryan in ever ever meaning my
first one was of lesbian porn yeah it
was on a TV channel called Bravo that at
ten o'clock turned in or whatever the
porn channel yeah and it was softcore
and they were like from the future
dressed as like half alien without
Sheikh cetera I don't remember that I do
remember that yeah I used to crush I
mean you had a because there was no
pausing live TV accuses the wrong cut
moment you have to be ready you have to
have everything organized in your level
organization organizes back for sort of
into a what about Eurotrash your trust
was there was it wasn't up to scratch
for me like you could not know one go
over that was - yeah you might be torn
or humor trashed
was it year or a trash it was a like a
French show that was shown in the UK
back in the day or the channel for your
Belgium summit European with European
humour and these that just had them but
girl Lulu were the massive tits on there
would come her tits are so big they
eventually killed her true story I think
okay I didn't know this or I just like
this is getting darker isn't it I also
just knew it was on because you know I
can be myself for the game I just don't
yeah who is this fellow compiler we
actually talk to him outside of the
podcaster is a bit like this - yeah yeah
he's not laddie is he logan Paul's very
much sure he's laddie off-camera no he's
he's not actually that laddie is he no I
like so there was seen him after the
fight I was having a drink with him and
we had a good little chat there and then
his girlfriend was being super nice to
me
and she was like you're gonna go so far
like you're really good at interviews
but yeah and I was like no Chloe [__]
Bennet and he nudged him and he went I
think a minute she was very pretty I
must admit that was one thing that hits
you when you talk in this girl but
anyway and then after were tailings in
there was any girls to say like this was
like I don't know it must what - sup bro
three in the mornin although this kids
just being in a fight where he's getting
his face punch - held by JJ and he goes
dude man I'd love to stay up a chat
because I am [__] this girl in a month
so I gotta go we've gotten through this
[__] is Reba so this is a sort of Joe
Rogan wore this on a podcast and I was
like actually I'm exactly quite and I
thought I thought I'd get a tribute to
him even though it's a tribute to
another us a guy I referenced the movie
very often but you know the movie Santa
Claus very not Santa Claus off the roof
and he saw a become Santa Claus everyone
in my podcast night yeah exactly is
mainly because I think one day you're
gonna try and get Joe Rogan on a roof
and then knock him off the Carson
recently my dream job is to be a UFC
comment it and someone compared
commented stop stop trying to be Jorgen
I thought was that I'd like to do his
job I don't want to be him yes no point
am I sort of not supposed to emulate and
like take influence from other people
aren't you
I don't know Ricky's your face I was
waiting for it ever since that left his
mouth I mean I was just waiting we both
do do you get that as well about the
Chaves thing a lot yeah because I do
clearly rip them up well your humor if
your passion in the airless or the exact
same as another person who's who's gone
where you want to go in life yeah
is there anything wrong in like just
because I watch his stuff all the time
I'll happily watch his stand-up shows
four or five times really yeah yeah
laughs yes commitment yeah yeah but but
if you started did if you had got an
idea for a sitcom there's something
we're in an office like fair enough then
it's taking it yeah yeah or you start
literally trying to like yeah like rip
him off entirely I don't think either of
us I tried to do that we're trying to
like use inspiration and do what they do
and one way I want when I was 15 I went
to it like a hippie festival with with
my parent and one of my parents and I
remember there was like a tent we
couldn't do anything and it was about
like I was wandering around on my own
weirdly at like a story before it's so
funny and I went um I went into the tent
and I was it side now it's just like I
goes up to this hippie guy and I was
like yeah I wanna do some stand-up and
the guy was like so I in my head I had
all I was gonna do is go up and do Ricky
Gervais jokes to a crowd of people who
didn't know that they were Ricky Gervais
Stokes and so I'm selling this tent I
was just going through it I was like
okay I'll go out there and I'll do the
whole I'll do the Bible bit that he does
and I'll do the bit where he does the
elephant thing and things like that it's
crowded be cracking up
and then last minute I had like a crisis
of conscience like but they're not my
joke they go welcome to stage young
comedian now and I just walked out I
just couldn't stay well I thought this
was though not only holds me now another
hippy hippy bunnies went what when he
says foot back into my arms no there was
one hippie who really sort of took a
shine to you almost on a strange level
there are a lot of hippies who take a
shine to me I was having this chat in
the office the other day it was just not
when you were young lad or remembers at
the same tent no a different tent it was
an obsession x2 you're young
next door but what's weird about hippies
is like they don't understand when
they're being like sexually creepy you
know what I mean because they've they
don't see they're like free love and
then lo sort of thing so now I really
love any age is over soon yeah when they
are being a bit weird but pedo yeah
they don't know but you know you feel it
what if they do know but that's just a
great way for a pedo to be a pedo
without being outed as a pedo yeah
that's a really good point and Marion
they're also in self denial you know
they won't yeah you know this is goes
within the first five minutes yeah it's
not watching it with any video and we're
what sought in the Loess lot since we
last seen you yes the mean the me like
the the first thing to happen was that
so a lo video yeah which one that the
calendar yeah yeah what's on the list
she just there was one there's this kid
right [__] knows what his name is but he
keeps making videos called
why insert youtubers name here channel
has died I can help ya I start watching
her on the site he's like a BTech women
II know but I like he's he's got that
delivery that will delivery but it's he
does his research and I quite like that
among I'm like that okay he's got that
will delivery but he does his reasons I
just mean like he's more he gives really
informative breakdowns of what's going
wrong on so monster online its you just
find yourself like I understand that
you're sort of making a channel about
other people's channels going down and
there's something sort of a bit shitty
about that like you've gotta come with
something else but but as a you young
youtuber I kind of rate what he was
doing a little bit like he's commented
an angle and it's kind of like it's kind
of interested bit like a [__] YouTube
Bloomberg you know you know in stocks
and shares go up and down and Bloomberg
do reports on the companies he's a bit
like that like that yeah no I don't mean
it in like the bad way I mean like
Bloomberg's just very high production
value in bedroom fair play um he's that
he's done videos before where he's like
so it'll be a similar topic to what I've
done yeah and then he'll just use all my
points yes
it's fine but partly like the emulating
people that you know though yeah you
imagine is watching your staff and then
there is a common what the phrases but
you basically do what you've seen but
you don't know that you're replicating
it you're basically you think of it as
your own thoughts so I imagine you watch
is something two days before yours few
days that you he goes yeah yeah yeah so
how do you feel knowing that you're sort
of you're one of the originated as it
being like a youtube critic and now that
there's this new wave of people like him
comment are you like like does it give
it a rest mate what would you say to
people like that coming through to the
body or to watch many of them I watched
him because I was in a few of the
thumbnail so obviously I'm interested
but I don't tend to watch channels going
downhill at the time yeah I don't tend
to watch people like that because then
if I if I watch how much this guy all
the time somebody does something he
makes video about it exactly what you
just said when I make my video in two
days time I'm just gonna be copying the
points even though I might genuinely
believe I mean so I tend to stay away
from stuff like that I tend to stay away
from uploading content mainly yeah is
what I do I think that's really become
like a trend on YouTube more mysterious
no it has gone a bit different than
hasn't it like I felt like even last
year there was something maybe I'm just
being influenced by will because he was
on that like every to do cry oh yeah I
felt like uploading all the time was
like a thing like and you had a spy
upload every couple of days everything
and then recently it doesn't matter as
much people said like it people have
been talking about youtuber burn out
recently that happening and I've also
noticed one thing I don't know whether
you've both notices as well big
youtubers they're now load uploading
4-minute videos and then so like david
dobrik is doing four minute videos and
then go and go and watch that my
reactions on instagram or snapchat or
something which is quite interesting
what is that just to just to be able to
do socials everywhere else
I don't know cons looking at me as if
I'm saying it wrong is that right or
wrong it's about right yeah it's almost
another pot of the point I'm making is
the trend there's a triplet there's
always a trickle-down effect like little
youtubers look at what the big
eyes are doing and copy that so like
when like people like Logan and like if
Logan and JJ for example take a break
because in the training and then they
upload a video
it's wish sayin that because they
haven't uploaded in a while the
anticipation builds more so than it
would do but you have to get at that
level where people give a [__] there if
they're at the top of the tree are they
so I don't know I just feel like yeah
people are concentrating more on doing
maybe a little bit of a longer more
quality video than just [__] out
stuff that we a quill used to do yeah
yeah and it was good I prefer that way
yeah I'd rather get give me a longer
quality video than a [__] [__] Sol
majani do I also kind of like I know
there's trends on YouTube I kind of want
to see it becoming a bit more diverse so
some people taking the short video route
some people taking the longer people
what I get a bit annoyed at is everyone
jumping on a trend and again that's the
way that trends work but I want to see a
bit more diversity I don't want to see
some people doing like you know it's
further why people are doing podcast I
doing podcasts YouTube's one of the
worst places I feel for like fishbowl
copying everybody else cuz it's hard not
to do we're all in the same game and
then someone sees something work I know
like when the when the disc trucks were
on and stuff like that now we've got
boxer and but I feel like it's cool the
gorath trans but as long as your channel
has all that stuff going on as well yeah
that's cool it's when you get one
youtuber who just just flaws with the
[__] River wherever it's going
what their channel just becomes that one
thing I think some people their
personality is so different to everyone
else such as yourself such as Steven I
like to think me as well so I'm a
miserable [__] that when you do jump
on trends you add something different to
the trail anyway you know I mean whereas
some people and
there's like there's there's no don't
even know many names but it's like a
bowl of like very similar type vloggy
people put and put your hand in you'll
pick one of the month as soon as each
other yeah the same thing yeah they look
the same sound the same do the same so
when they're all doing the same kind of
videos it just becomes a bit dead you
know they are the ones who wash it out
and kill it yeah than anyone yeah yeah
yeah yeah Stephen I wish Stephen would
do this is such a random pie but like I
love his his sketches I'd love him to
guava do like the different kind of
series where he's being himself more I'd
love to hear his opinions on what I'm
saying like like these a little bit like
maybe a sure like a bit like what you
and will and a couple just to see how he
you would take that on mmm he cuz when
he has been on with Enys at Will's
channel he has actually had some quite
good perceptions by her the problem for
him is he's not a very judgmental person
no and it takes a level of being able to
like sit back and judge who's really
critical of himself he's critical
himself but very rare so great you know
sometimes I'll be like oh you know you
want to evaluate its last video be able
to know I don't - you almost doesn't
want to upset than those knees talking
dude he's quite a kind guy unless you
can tell he's like like with you with me
will he'll sort of he'll evaluate in a
very kind way you don't want to hurt
anyone do you know what I mean yeah
whereas there are other youtubers who
almost have that you know this
conscience was a bit more on mine in
your level we'd get some cracking like
yeah do you ever finish a bit like with
the zoella thing you must have also seen
the other side where you where you see
you you know she's not a greedy little
[__] do you know that you know that yeah
so when you feel I'm never I'm not cuz
I'm you're not convinced if it's a 50
pound advent calendar isn't it yeah how
can anyone justify that if you start
selling up for 50 pounds I used to I'd
say you're greedy for such come and say
however Brian you might be big and a
[__] massage yeah that's mend yeah
and the whole I suppose there was a
whole series of things like but for me
it felt like it was a bit similar to
logan paul situation where it
came a lack of context in their lives
and so you just start you that the
beasts get so big it's hard to then
every little decision almost becomes
like oh wait what's going on here and
suddenly I think there's two ways of
dealing with a with us when when you
[__] up Mia Jolly online yeah
you can either trying hide or you can
own it and I felt like at least Logan
did a video right afterwards a [__] up
as much as some people might think it
was [__] ownership of the situation
yeah sorry video with zoella hiding it
on a second Channel at the end of one of
her videos and then blaming it on boots
at the same time yeah I kind of felt
like oh you have not played this well
now all no no if anything you've shown
more guilt by like sliding it in there
be like oh yeah I'll deal with it there
yeah then if you just don't ah the whole
world's talking about this so I lie like
you're not fooling anyone right now
no take ownership of this [__] yeah and
for me it made me believe her a lot less
by how she dealt with it yeah it was
more yeah and and the fact that I can't
real where was she I don't to misquote
or in case it's not true about the fact
that she said that it was I think she
said that boots price didn't get much
say in the price she said she had no say
in the price up to it yeah don't do it
then because if I was to release a bit
of merch and they came to me and told me
the price point and it was that [__]
high I pull out of it I wouldn't pull
out of it because that that is mental
what do you think the assumption there
was well something good will be in it so
it'll sort of be worth the fifty
oh that's maybe that would be much
because we was ten like you buy [__]
FIFA Call of Duty you could buy a lot of
things yeah I should put Call of Duty in
the color nothing that's worth it what's
really killer about your video is you
did go through everything and go it's
worth 20 P this is worth like at 5 quid
or whatever yeah and never added up to
that nerdy no though so that was part of
the frustration as well as if you were
buying something that was worth 50
pounds when you got it and it was like a
solid jumper and all these things that
would have been a slightly different
case but it doesn't have to be worth
fifty pounds it can be worth twenty-five
pound you can sell it at 50 because oh
well there is a brand but it was because
it was so far from that and I think that
a bit
the the the gray area or the massive
gray area came from the fact that it was
like you're buying a lucky dip right
that's what you're doing like yeah yeah
you can research it but the kids don't
really want to research it because the
joy comes from the surprise yeah so
you're buying a lucky dip and then I fit
I thought of reviewing it I bought the
thing I had a little look online and it
was just it became so apparent every
every a bag of glitter like this is
beyond a joke now it got to a point
where this is gonna be a funny little
parody thing like I don't know what
you're getting this old it was it was so
bad so when you say to me that I know
she's not a greedy [__] yeah I have to
agree I don't know because you would not
do that you would not do that I would
not do that like I'm sure she's not evil
like I know she's not evil and she's
that she's brought out a lot of other
merch that I've never touched upon like
ever she's brought out thousands
hundreds of products I've never touched
upon it but that was just so [__] watch
your video back was it it was almost as
if you couldn't believe your luck as to
how as to how bad the stuff was served
someone who your bread and butter is in
that Juvia style to pick things apart
the way he did the Bible for example
yeah to have similar so much to work
with fairs like yeah so fun I'm the only
person to get my money's worth from that
calendar absolutely yeah yeah yeah CPM
was really high yeah
and they of course not unlike mainstream
media sort of looked in as well and
you've got a lot of the other side
because we all know about the public
exposure yeah how did you feel about the
was there anyone who messes you from the
YouTube community who saying you're well
out of order here like this yes we had
the obvious ones thinking like I'd
rather our boyfriend and that that
circle but do you think they come to you
director with it mark never never ever
direct like if the first person I think
I ever heard even talked about as
defender and to be fair he didn't I
don't think you slag me off I'm not sure
he's well within his right to but was
Joe sugg when he came on your podcast
that was the first time I was that wax
and was actually speaking about this
right because no one was ever ever ever
mentioned anything I had way more a lot
saying this from a braggy
point of view I'm saying this from an
shocked as well had way more people in
the community the blue tickers the
mainstream celebrities getting in touch
right and are all for it I'm talking
mainstream celebrities where one day I'm
like the [__] this is this is mad so so
that's kind of it seemed to change your
career a little bit though it did but it
kind of put me on a bit of a it was kind
of like a poison chalice as well because
then from that moment on I've always
been somebody that picks apart things I
was going to say for the good of all the
bad but mainly for bad I try and find
the comedy out of these things like like
that's that's your cue above all else
that's why I do it I keep getting a lot
of people at the moment tell me keep
asking me to make videos about this
Chris Ingham guy yeah who may or may not
be a sexual deviance allegedly yeah lots
of string I've avoided that like the
plague because I'm the type o blood I
want to see the [__] first exactly and
I know that there's been other videos
made but I'm just like when everything
comes out then we can make work yeah
judgments and I feel like isn't look
great with a [__] calendar or an empty
book or something like that or Alfie
deyes doing the one pound challenge
there's comedy to be had in that for
sure and if you feel like you can't
punch up at these people then it's later
like point yeah then then then it's
ridiculous but with something like the
christening and thing that's for
something way bigger than me right don't
go to the place or go like what am I
gonna do it could be a pedophile guys
like that's like where's the cat where's
your so slightly in the comedy out of
their comedy there would have to come
from at quite a dark place where it's
sort of like ah he touch girls or
whatever which we don't know if you did
but I'd like that would be what people
be saying for sure and with the whole
Jimmy Savile stuff right me times past
times past and and jokes you can I
believe you can joke about anything but
there is a time and a place and if this
these accusations going on now so
there's girls that are hurting now so if
I'm making jokes about these victims now
you never make jokes about the victims
you know remember if you're making jokes
now and these girls are watching it it's
gonna crush him twice as bad as I
assumed anything that was like
you know it doesn't really suit your
style of comedy which is a little bit
more you slightly techni moral high
ground on things or sort of a play that
the people's here over there times you
know and whether you choose to or not
yeah it would definitely not suit your
comedies and then be making jokes about
people are in that situation you know
but what about so then it then goes on
from there where you you've obviously
benefited a lot from the net some of the
negativity mmm do you think that had a
bit of an effect on how you felt about
your channel like there are a lot of
people looking in and hating as well as
enjoying your stuff did you get much of
a but lush from those well afar yeah
when I did the logon thing there was a
good like I don't know five percent of
the comments who were on his site you
know I mean the original login video mmm
not not particularly nothing that ever
made it then nothing ever stood out and
made me think that maybe I've
overstepped the mark yet at all well I
think I think that their comments
genuinely wouldn't affect me either
like I know I completely understand how
like the whole world was against Logan
right but I'm never going to do anything
to that degree I'm really gonna pick
people apart and if if my 50% of my
audience turn on me tomorrow and call me
out for something I'm kind of respect
vixx it's like maybe I have genuine
least I said this onstage at summer in
the city right something because like
with me in you we don't cut our stuff
we're very like scathing and the way we
we say things and because we have this
honest or very raw relationship with our
audience I feel if I do [__] up and say
something that's at a point not only
will you and you and all my YouTube
mates tell me but my audience will as
well I don't want them to latch on to my
coattails and just be are you great
everything you do is so there mate I
don't want that because I will [__] up I
say so I live by the sword die by the
sword in that sense exactly exactly if
Ricky Gervais came out tomorrow and was
saying some obscure stuff about
something that I opposed I wouldn't just
be like okay Ricky are you right I'd
feel I'd feel the point of telling him
just cuz you I'd lie someone doesn't
mean not saying you idolize me but just
just cuz you look up to someone of you
here watch their videos doesn't mean
that they're always gonna be right and I
feel like
because I'm criticized people all the
time I'm open to criticism that's that I
don't take this game too seriously
Toby's nephew well I'm at Auburn the
criticism like how do you how do you
feel when you get criticism because I
know oh yeah I to be honest with you
does it bother you it depends on where
it's coming from because if it's legit
criticism and it's something I can
really the thing is I think my
frustrations come from like context like
people if people knew what like so if
someone messages and says this video was
[__] and then I know everything that
went wrong in my week before that and
nor like I don't know let's say
everything was going [__] now so I'm a
really bad timely person in life and I'm
like do you realize like how hard it was
just to get that [__] video out like
I see a comment like that and that gets
to us yeah because they don't know what
the [__] is going on or or if it
absolutely nails something that you are
what I hate is when you know there's
something even um wrong in a video so
maybe this sounds like slightly off but
you've put so much into it or you know
you know that you could have done you
know you wouldn't been to another
country or something people know you
don't hear it should have a man using I
should have seen that mmm that sort of
thing yes we had an issue with 100
podcasts where the sound was upset it'd
be [__] terrible long story but it
was an issue that I was out of my
control
hmm and and I got a few messages and
there was there was a point where
someone messaged me like the son was
[__] I'll just say I just blocked
them cuz I thought myself like I'm doing
everything I [__] can't yeah like and
believe me yeah you will never be aware
of anything going on my channel I'm not
already aware yeah because I literally
give everything I can to my channels
yeah
if I'd prefer my criticism to coming up
form of like what kind of content they'd
want me to make as opposed to the
quality yeah because I'm operating at
100% already I can't be any better than
what I am in terms of the videos I make
and at least I feel that way there's
always room to grow but like in my
ability right now I'm given a hundred
percent of what I've got
so I'd rather the criticism come from
like I'd rather see me like when people
say the one is to make a football
hangover video I haven't done them for a
while because Jim when mance Italy ran
away with the title last year I just was
like Newcastle yeah we're we're an
average side were not great we're not
terrible it's just basic football city
of won the league there's not at all I
felt like there's nothing to talk about
and all the things were happening on
YouTube that was spotting me I said I've
always I've always a little fighting
more than football I just always have
but football was what sort of made me
named on so now people are like hold and
as to what I used to do and I respect
that like when people say I wish you'd
do more football hung all of us but
equally I want them to respect that this
is what I want to do right now Jeremy
and maybe I'll go back that way in the
future but like you do find different
things like yeah if nor the five hour
livestream I did on football yeah last
weekend yeah like five and it was
constant football analysis on vibe I was
solid mmm one thing I I guess we
definitely had this experience below
because we spent hours talking about how
you were gonna do the Logan Paul podcast
beforehand like Brian was always running
ideas past me should I go down this way
it's way and it was really good by the
way he absolutely smashed it really well
well there was there was a couple of
that basically we realized before this
because I watched the Casey interview
because he recommended it I reckon I was
like I cannot do an interview like that
it was [__] painful I watched about
ten minutes and I can do 23 year old lad
getting a touched shut stone
good night that's it really like yeah he
[__] up but like I just but the thing
is with Casey
no disrespect the man is one of the
legends of YouTube like fully
yeah it's just like he's not an
interviewer so I had to find a way of I
also think he went in there thinking
there was gonna be a different exchange
and it was almost like it was a slight
sort of Logan though yeah it was a good
precursor to that you end up yeah it
helped me out a lot it held you out
because you you could have maybe felt
like you had to be a little bit more
harsh but you sort of almost saw the
reaction to
being that way and so got to take the
other angle I'm not saying we're not
smart enough to come up with that angle
ourselves but and but what I guess is
anyway but it was just a guarantee of
this is what happens if you just try and
call the the lot of [__] what I was he
won't open up yeah do you do either of
you ever get to a point where you are
taking a person apart and then you
remember like this is actually just a
person who's very fallible yeah yeah
have you ever not released a video for
that reason what you've absolutely
destroyed someone and then gone yeah I
can't do that I've definitely cut a lot
out the only way that I justify it or
try to justify it is that I'd back in
the day I would just call people
cancerous a queue it and it's very
juvenile very boring people saying my
content is now but you always just put
the description but I think if you go on
my channel and you and you look at what
I've spoken about it's not it's not
really them as if not really anything
that they can't help right so what I
used to do is I used to slag off a lot
Alfie's content and then I realized
that's just such a that's just such a
wanker thing to do because the contents
not aimed at me yeah like so I think I
did a lot of growing up in that respect
who cares if I don't like the content
that's that's like me watching I hate an
archery program and this is [__] [__]
well yeah because I don't enjoy archery
nitration sir
so when he's doing the 1 pound video and
I'm just it's so ignorant and whether
whether or not you meant it to be it's
it's ignorant because that's what you
can and says that's what Tories are like
yeah I'm not a Tory
god bless him crucified I felt so bad
for him that you had to do a video when
you and Luthor
I'm doing that was a moment yeah it was
so good
mainstream journalists were using that
at one point right I am NOT a Tory I
watch it I remember just being in like
oh my god it's gotten to the point where
you have to deny being a conservative
like I think that like him when I was
watching his apology yeah like I'm
watching it and Jenna thought for how we
[__] up and his apology was probably
one of the most genuine apologies how
was I all right yeah he's really
apologized yet he means they're sucking
[__] tell with them and then out of
know he goes on there's just one flavor
my wife and I was like where are you
going at this like dude like stop yeah
like they're all just pulling the words
but yeah that was I think went answer
your question in regards to that like
how much you can smash someone or what
you should I think the there's a few
things I've said obviously about women
and stuff like that in the past session
they said but also in the login video I
already edited one thing out which was
there you see me walk home like
afterwards I was like when I see you I'm
gonna look I said if I leave that in
I've lost all credibility I need you
like in in the calm of editing the video
I was like alright that just doesn't
need to be there because that's not
really how I feel about the guy I'm just
pissed off of what he did yeah but I
must submit the keemstar fouseytube
has been a bit of a learning experience
for me as as a as a breaking people down
experience in terms of keemstar has
critiqued for see tubes actions and the
things he said and fairly for the most
part but then there's a point where
because firstly to message me after I
did the original Logan video saying you
know can you give me some sort of
support I was kind of like um I'm not
the guy for this like you know I'm not
being a contrary Val just don't know I
wouldn't know where to start being
against right
dude sort of because he was talking to
you about his addiction wasn't he or is
he knows that can you be my sponsor type
thing and I now respected like where he
was coming from it was nice that he
thought it wasn't that way about equally
I didn't really know who knew who I
didn't know who fouseytube was at the
time I was like he has this american
youtuber i was like you know we messaged
a little bit but anyway when keemstar
was fully heavily critic in russia and
then fouseytube looked like he was
having a breakdown there was a part of
me watching this like oh [__] if the
tube does anything stupid like keemstar
is gonna look this like this is not
gonna go well the YouTube community is
gonna be terrible like not just because
obviously you don't want fouseytube to
[__] yeah got like anything happened
to the guy even though some of the
things he says are ridiculous but can I
just interject and say I get what you
say in a hundred percent but when and
before I get so I'll say with the kind
of like the books and the merch or stuff
like that right I'm not comparing it to
what to the story I'm about to say it's
not half as bad but there was a youtuber
about four or five years ago called v1i
who I often make jokes about yeah who no
idea who he basically got he admitted
all this right so this is why I openly
talk about all the time because it's
it's it's fact but he got one of this he
was it he was like it's just the vlogger
guy and he got one of these young fans
round she was under the age of 16 and
all she was 16 I don't know don't quote
me on it and but it was it was murky
waters I think she was just slightly
under he got he got a drunk and he slept
with her and she came out and said she
didn't want to do it and he put her in
that position and it was like I think
it's do they call it statutory rape is
that what it is and he came out right
and I've made a video about it this was
one of the first videos where I really
was like I'm actually gonna make a whole
video about this and I was just saying
[__] off away from YouTube now like you
don't like you should be locked up
alright
then he made a video and it was like one
of these apology videos and he was like
I'm from a Mormon background so I didn't
realise mental and then he basically
started without actually saying the
words he was basically insinuate and
that my life's gonna go from there
point if you all start saying this and I
can do some dodgy [__] like I could it's
basically insinuating that you could
kill himself like and then it's late
we've gotten sort of yeah and that made
me think right this is dodgy because if
he does kill himself I've got a video
that's getting quite a lot of use
telling calling him what he is and tell
him to [__] off but then I thought just
because I'm critiquing the negative
stuff you've done for what I believe to
be the right reasons I'm not just going
how look at your hair you're a bit fat
John I mean I'm actually pointing out
the bad things if they then do go into
anything bad I don't think that's on the
commentator I don't think that's on the
person that picked them apart I don't
think it is but what I'm seeing as
someone who just doesn't want someone to
die in that respect even if I do think
that way is I think there's certain
people who you know can handle it then
this sort what I'm saying is before
before I say something now
I would be a little bit more like
alright can this person take what so I
new law can continue where I could just
tell ya when I made that video the guy
is just the way yes - I mean but then
there's that argument dude but do you
know because you don't really know
what's going on in Jeff's head
completely like lately so but I see what
you're saying it's a tough one is what
I'm saying there's like because I I
heard a story for a locally from me last
week of someone he was getting [__] at
school and for being gay and they took
her own life and like a sick [__] you
know fourteen-year-old kid or whatever
and it just makes you think like that
just made me think like obviously you
relate things back to YouTube and even
God would criticize people all the time
like sometimes people just don't know
the damage that they're doing when they
do in it and it's a totally different
situation but I'm just more like aware
of it like there's nothing you can
really do is stop when you're
criticizing something someone you can't
really predict what's going to happen
next but let's just say there's certain
youtubers like fouseytube
who I would stay the [__] away from
people aren't that reason i I see what
you're saying put the opposite view for
I think YouTube is probably quite a
specific place where because of the way
the community is
you you can critique other people might
get seen as sort of a platform to be
able to do that and have that honest
conversation it's become quite normal
isn't it but I think it always is within
comedy you've got you've had Mock the
Week for you as they mock politicians
all the time knows that the thing
Charlie Zucker that part of that is
though those politicians and the people
that Charlie Brooker mark hmm have all
chosen to put themselves almost
knowingly into a political position
where it's seen as you're taking a
position in society you're taking that
responsibility and there is something
about it all and I'm not critiquing what
either of you are saying but that does
sometimes stink a little bit even the
critiques and of that like white
privilege oh sure we're all sitting
around smell our own farts and loving it
sort of thing like we're we're all
making money out of this I'm not saying
that you're coming from angular that
you're coming from that angle
but it does smell a little bit like that
do you know I mean we're well I'm
betting this guy cuz he's making [__]
content but I'm making contact about his
[__] content so how good am i and I you
to sort of take that angle of we're no
better than anyone else but there are
people out there who are very judgmental
about it and and the weird thing for me
is how real it feels like if you step
out of it and I talked to one of my
family what's YouTube they're like why
the [__] is any of this matter
like how does any of this matter to
anyone because literally it it feels
fictional to other people because
they're like what doesn't affect me in
any way but it has that vibe of you know
like a load of privileged people sitting
around or or making money out of it it
feels a little bit like a ring almost
where they just pass it around but
doesn't start that with autism no and
that's what I'm saying is it feels a bit
like YouTube didn't build itself to get
to this point but actually and it never
thought well there'd be all these white
privilege vloggers it thought they'll be
a you know there'll be a black guy over
there be an Indian guy or a beer Chinese
guy and they'll be very diverse but it
didn't quite work out that way like it
not so it's country but I mean it's the
lone leaders really isn't it and that's
part the point is it almost it does feel
a little bit like if you two kept making
this content we have this conversation
yesterday you were talking about how you
don't feel like you can keep making the
same content because not only will you
get personally bored you won't see your
own personal progression uh-huh so if
you were 30 and still making the same
content you you just like you'd look at
yourself and go what the [__] what might
do it
yeah because I started this when I was
20 22 you know whatever age it's been oh
you almost have but you almost have to
go through that we as a like as the
YouTube community almost have to go
through this phase and it will pass if
it's always this way and in five years
time it's this way
well some people's not going to [__] but
we're really we really still here you
know I mean yeah because that would be
disappointing to me yeah we were still
in that position where we were all
making the same vlogs and still doing
that same stuff and you've both
expressed that you both want to do
better is probably why you're doing your
box why are youtubers as I it is for
everyone and then some people aren't
going to have the capabilities to make a
[__] documentary oh wow so there are
girls out there who are currently 50 you
know whatever thinking let's do a
shopping haul Jeremy no Sue Ellen and
not really fully realizing like that has
been done to death on YouTube like this
do you I also think that's a start for
them it is all I'm saying and they'll
grow from that
but equally you've got to start
somewhere it doesn't yeah it doesn't
become a Scorsese straightaway you come
on in and documentary I mean yes Khan
yes absolutely sold destroy and win like
for me I may do a video of my comedy
hero Ricky Gervais so got an hour along
with them what a privilege best moment
of my life wasted it ah blah nice sorry
sorry that 150k views okay all the
comments are not other comments a few
comments oh this is great in all but
have you noticed only White's got a new
t-shirt out it's like okay ah next week
a [__] t-shirt isn't it I'm almost a
parody of myself by this point here look
at this t-shirt 300k views mmm it's like
[__] me I need to pay the rent but I
also need to keep my mind sane because I
don't why don't you be [__] slag and
stuff off all the time that's why I try
and do it for you and far between now
and all my plans I've got for the future
are very much away from my soon though
yeah but it's but if they but that's not
to say if they don't if one of these
vloggers comes out with the next most
ridiculous thing ever but I'm not gonna
pick it apart because I do ultimately a
joy personals about yeah yeah
what when was so rewinding when that
zoella video drop I'm a mouth under will
actually and we were both like all this
kids gone now like if he if he plays
this situation correctly your
million-plus and then and then because
the I don't know what Groff it was but I
remembered spinning [__] me it was mad
hundred thousands if I wasn't in a week
I know it I don't know actually fifty K
Damon he I was like it was quarter of a
million awake it was quarter of a
million about my place yeah it was on
that look important numbers genuinely
though I was like rooting for you to to
play your cards right at that point and
I felt like all of a sudden no I was i I
was just expected you did a few more
videos but then all of a sudden you were
like you put the cards away and you sort
of chilled and I was like whoa what and
fork like I mean I was talking to will
about because he's the [__] the expert
to me on YouTube in terms of like when
to do what to do and how to how to get
the most out of your buzz yeah and you
just stop capitalizing completely so I
mean you're a man of your word and what
you're saying is you do get bored of
that [__] but why why didn't you make
them more so a lot because it's I did
the video on the calendar is funny and
whatever and then I did my follow-up one
which was I had the idea already to make
my own calendar and fill it with even
worse stuff because that was like the
natural sequel and then I felt like any
more of that and then it does just
become boolean and attacking someone
over and over again
so now when I if I mention it I do still
mention it I will put a little a little
one-liner in in a video she's probably
not gonna say and if she does it doesn't
it's not going to do it's not it's any
degree of them or them original videos
were some people felt that even my first
video was too much you know what I mean
like yeah like well will it will that
will happily uploaded a video where he
was saying about Oh everyone's just
making videos on the calendar and like
I'll leave like the [__] calendar and
stuff like that and I was like yeah
that's that's fair enough
I don't want to ride that wave anymore
about the calendar what I'm saying is
like YouTube like it wasn't long after
that video that you were just like the
video slowed down and stopped fire just
because I unknown as this guy that
critiques people and takes the piss and
stuff it's not necessarily how I want to
be known but I'm good at it and but I
can't I'm not I'm not passionately and
I'm not passionate enough to do it all
the [__] time it's it's draining I'm
actually quite a happy person I'm
actually quite a chirpy person I'm quite
an emotional person for sure right sure
and I actually this gonna sound really
wanky and softly but I do actually have
a lot of love
so to go onto YouTube every [__] week
and go that zaps the [__] life at
yourself you don't want to be notified
it really reminds me of when I got known
for the Newcastle rant videos and I was
like this is not this is a wind order me
after watching a Newcastle game really
pissed and right after the games
finished yeah this isn't what you're
you're not getting the regular version
of major in the week no and I began to
hate those videos yeah I don't know if
this is a compliment or not but I see a
lot of myself in you because I think
you're a very emotional person as well
as we lay a sore in the original Logan
pool video but when I first started
watching your videos when you were doing
the football hangout of her you were
very similar to me and you were swaggin
footballers off and swearing and that
was funny as [__] but I'd watch it laugh
all the time and then you and then you
brought the podcast out and you was
putting your own emotion into things
your own thoughts and things now singing
[__] me this isn't just a big lads that
[__] is do you know what I mean that
you've got another dimension to you and
that's when you became a lot more
likable to the public and that's when I
was like this guy's actually class like
and then you and then I warm to you and
you warm to everyone else and that's
kind of like what I want to do I kind of
I I see the funny things I see the funny
side of things more than I see the [__]
side of things
I hope sometimes that crosses over and
the lines are blurred but that's what I
want to do I don't just want to
constantly be calling people out for
plus another reason the videos dried up
it's because I as you said when my eyes
lit up because the calendar was so bad
I then found that nothing else is going
to be that bad right because everyone's
gonna tone down a little bit and if I
then go from that to I know only white
it is Christmas stuff which was mental
as well but then in January and February
what just because someone's up got a new
t-shirt out how boring is that gonna
care I feel like that's gonna kill the
channel more than just me not upload it
right that's you don't want to make that
transition that a similar way that I
have to just to break out of that box
that people look want to put you in now
because you kind of put yourself there a
little bit as did I
without yeah yeah so this is where I've
noticed you thinking about doing
stand-up documentaries boxing all that I
see being being just growing from where
you are now yeah but if I'm not mistaken
in that time also you had a death in the
family as well didn't you yeah so last
last year it's all about this is yeah
yeah yeah December it was a weird one as
well right because so my granddad died
but that's that and it was a weird one
for me because I've never it resonated
with me when you were saying to Logan
Paul about how he didn't take that
seriously cuz I was like [__] like I'm
so lucky touch with that aside from that
the case that we're talking about I've
never really experienced death like at
all my great man died as as you wasn't
they do yeah when I was like 10 I want
to say so I never really experienced
that and the thing that sort of threw
might give my head a wobble a little bit
was when my granddad died he found out
he had bone cancer two weeks before he
died and he died at that a day after my
dad's birthday
and so obviously my dad took it bad I
took it quite badly and it wasn't the
death that got to me it was the fact
that because I was never that close to
my granddad some members of my family
who lived closer to him what kind of
almost like why are you feeling bad
about it yeah I remember I went to this
is mental I've never told this story
before but I went to his funeral
and I was on the second row so all his
kids were they are quite a few and then
the grandkids were there
and I remember a satin person in my
family who was closer to my grandma than
I was was was saying why are they on the
second row why is he on the second row
and I'm getting upset mainly because the
whole time I'm looking at my dad and
it's the first time I seen my dad choke
up and that's hard to [__] take is a
sure you can imagine so I'm getting
choked up and I'm trying to keep strong
for my sister and people that people are
saying you can't you can't be upset you
can't be upset and that's spun my head
so much that I then went on a I went on
a bit of a downward slope and I seen
that and and and I kind of thought I
kind of thought like like I said like I
am emotional I do have more to me than
just [__] slag and things off and
then and then I videos became secondary
I didn't care enough about you I feel
yeah weird because you'd had such
success and you went from like I feel
like the next big thing on YouTube
like that period and then it was like
you'd break for a bit and I was like wow
like he's taking a break at the it felt
like because I didn't know what's going
on with this but I was like what's he
doing you know I mean I think during
that period I became actually angry and
that's what ruined the comedy side of
things party that's party grief though
isn't it like yeah you've got to be
lucky to take the piss I feel when I'm
on Form I know i'll be i'll be i'll feel
it before i get on camera I'm in a good
mood yeah I can't get on camera be funny
no no no no no it's in so and that's
part of the problem isn't it having
everyone sort of wait I mean maybe if
you've had death navami or whatever
you've witnessed people going through
grief and sort of trying to some people
blame other people and they say few nice
funerals in general there's there's
always undertones or like stuff going on
resentment is a vibe and I've seen I've
been to some funerals where it's like
you didn't really love them what you
doing and like it's that sort of almost
like a fight for who's hurting the most
and I I've seen some people got funerals
and cry and I know it's just because
they think that that's what you're
supposed to do not because they're
actually feeling that feel like that
must that this
because my immediate reaction to that is
I feel quite sorry for that person they
don't know how to feel in and wait
because look saying that okay now it's
almost like a performance for themselves
more than anything to show the world how
they're [__] so I went about six
funerals by the time I was like 24 my
god like and I was like one a year with
you that's so I got used to it in us but
as if people watch her you start
spotting [__] after like the third
[__] funeral that's happening again
is that not quite do you because you're
obviously you're both quite emotional
guys you know do you not look at those
people and feel a little bit sorry that
they can't feel or they feel that they
have to perform to other people when
it's such an emotional situation because
almost feels like they don't understand
then these people are doing it because
not because they're like I'm sad
therefore I'll cry which isn't what
you'd imagine a normal person feels
they're sort of like I'm supposed to be
sad so I think I'm gonna have a cry and
see how see how that works
do you know what I mean they're almost
testing it out there's something quite
sad people are strange that's it like we
on there's no set men you've now you're
supposed to feel especially when someone
dies but like equally like sometimes
that the people I've been closest to the
less I've cried at the funeral because
I've been that tell bent on keeping a
brave face for it you know I'm saying
whereas when I'm at the back or whatever
and it's not any pressure on me because
I've got it in spoke at funerals and
stuff like that before and he's [__]
heavy but obviously when you're not
under that pressure and you can just be
in the corner I don't know that's
probably what I've let it go the most
really I was nothing as a bit of a
problem when people other people tell
you how to be sad do you know what I
mean so when you're at a funeral someone
is crying and you're not it's sort of
like well you should be sad as well why
and if you're not crying they're sort of
you should feel guilty for not being as
sad as I am do you know what I mean yeah
which is unusual like it really blinds
people to to sort of like it blinds
people to so much hmm and then I imagine
they get away from the funeral I think
you to some extent had something there
was a real sense of perspective yeah in
your life like none of that no not
usually
are you definitely soon like I've woke
up a little bit in the last year like
I've seen you grow up a [__]
but like only because we do the same job
we're quite similar thickness and I
recognize some of the little things that
you're doing is like growing up I can
see it and because sometimes I forget
that you're like five years younger than
me over holding 25 there you go then so
well you say you we're both a little bit
older than Jackie's why I'm saying
you're one year younger than maybe
obviously I'm 41 this is 30 this year
this year so oh no need to hide it some
people say I'm still looking my twenties
you con them like you see them what yeah
what have you mean it your skin sorted
out we're gonna go to dr. Rachel and get
that plastic surgery [__] right come on
up in hot right
some people say they like mental age
gracefully but it turns out if you come
from new cars direct message of the day
literally after me last video the guy
saying your skin were terrible in this
video mitt you need to look after
yourself this guy once I was like it's
not really what you use mentor probably
watches me every week have I left a nice
comment in his life this game looks
[__] terrible I thought it was the I
thought was the great to be honest I
used on the video maybe I'm on the great
flame on the great it looks fine now
mate lived moment yeah I think the main
issue is well with people evaluating
against skiing and those sorts of things
when you're when you're younger maybe
you don't realize or when you don't have
bad skin it's hard to realize what it's
like to then feel that you know I've got
thick skin way more complete but when
know when I meet the air quite literally
but when you're you're like there's some
of the time some of the funniest lines I
think you've ever said to me
we were playing Xbox ones and I was like
why are you really bad at listen you
went curse these hooves when you can
make fun of it a realization though like
lately that I've never been good at
computer games like hardly ever numb
right ensure it's these [__] fingers
right and I even the game
I love I'm always I am the best that be
I'm never that guy I'll never be ninja
I'd right now out there right pay for it
though I played it once I was like this
isn't fun notice you only good at FIFA I
not build or play great finishing
terrible I don't play someone I just
can't score what would be the average
sort of score if you have to pick a song
I am yeah that's a no-brainer know what
that there's we can't talk about right
now but there's something that will
prove this fairly soon yeah oh we can't
talk about we're gonna play a game of
FIFA are we gonna play - no IDs on about
it I will [__] I will kill Brian yeah
absolutely
like my yeah they're bringing the
PlayStation 1 but apparently saw Western
Metal Gear Solid that was my favorite
game ever did you ever have like did you
have console before that as well
Mega Drive monster save Sega basically
Wow okay I remember going to some a kid
on our street got the first games
console on the street I remember was the
snares and everyone's just like those
are what a snare is like super super
noon eternal okay right and everyone
every kid went to their house the
popular guy yeah it was actually a twin
girls and they everyone my probably on
benefits just two irrelevant is he you
know what true it was that guy mystery
and then well no double bubble limit
yeah I remember just watching watching
and being like wow this is like I cannot
believe this and I was watching super
and remember thinking I really want to
be super Mario you get to put your life
where you stop nobody else was thinking
and that line nobody else was thinking I
want to be that pixelated Italian
starving man plumber
young plumbers never at the top of the
list
no no when you get older you realize
good trade good money but not as a kids
my dad the other day sold something on
online and this guy came out to pick it
up and he arrived in a gold like pickup
truck full gold it was like no not it
was like goddamn eyes being all over it
and he paid for it in a roll of 50 s my
dad was just out of interest what do you
do he went on the wager
yeah yeah he went up our mansion you
know I clean wheelie bins
this man had just made a business out of
cleaning the insides wheelie bins for
people to Jeff promote want to hire him
because they do a lot of really yeah he
got like her pound hump it was so quick
for him and so cheap that he now he does
it across the country and the guy just
make cleans wheelie bins and
multi-millionaire there we go
honestly you get a lot of interesting
even cons watching this people are gonna
be thinking about this podcast cons gone
who gives a [__] man I [__] filmed his
bollocks [__] out on the balcony with
him shouting someone's name in the
elephants
alright oh really
oh right now yeah I'm [__] it a slug
in the or friend he's all about the wage
yeah he's been cleaning video coming
soon college channel mini men to sit now
I'm going to go on yeah yeah so can I
say so yeah you've been through this
sort of period of a break yeah you seem
to be coming back to more regular stuff
and you're doing different kind of
content like the recent one about
foreigners in Britain and all that sort
of stuff also thought that the girl used
in the thumbnail was quite a pretty
young woman mmm
for the record yeah small thing is yeah
do you think of using an ugly person
mostly my unattractive right oh yeah
fine I'm often tells me that off behind
behind the camera
that's his perfect combination
they genuinely I've never said either
way really yeah religions never really
come into my sort of not fussy no
generally definitely coming to religion
never be the way forward for me though
because they've got sort of talk good
morals from day one right cross over
well is that as a Venn diagram I
wouldn't say it's your best will apply
so men they tend to be good sort of
proper women indoors and sort of stuff
like that done there right and you would
have to marry her just have to get into
the religious I think you ever had a kid
at school we had a kid at school I won't
say his name lovely guy then he said he
would not have sex until marriage and
yet left school at eighteen married
winning the money leaving school married
straight away straight way babies like
well you know really religious heavily
but I sort of I sort of thought I don't
think that's why religion tells you
religion go be eighteen I've met one of
those guys who's uh heavily when I was
diving actually was really heavily
religious dude what's those one is it
Mormons yeah yeah the ones who have
loads of kids and stuff they have to
fill yeah and the kids tend to help with
on the funny little hats but I remember
just been like I was like right okay and
he was diving he's like yeah I'm just
doing this for a few years till I got
enough money ER so I live I live off the
land sort of thing you know that's the
land you don't need any money I think we
needed some sort of a cushion applying
on trying genuinely pray harder he said
I never forget I don't know
remember this guy but I don't forget him
going yeah I was like when's the buns
the next one Jew anyway off tour buying
I was like so probably an offer for a
while a when I know when she's pregnant
that kind of keeping me hands oh [__] I
was like is that your preferred it was a
I prefer that was me so that was me like
22 years old listen 21 now remember like
it's like like that's a sign of
fertility for some people might be like
a status symbol you know what I mean
like oh you can get her pregnant can
have a family like so for him he's gonna
value that and like he's gonna reward
yourself mentally do you know he
rewarded her by the sounds of it yeah
with lots of dick yeah Wow did you do
you ever question him did you ever sort
of debate him it was actually a really
nice guy you just seemed a bit off is
that make sense
remember I'm on deck with him for 12
hours a day and all I've got to talk
about is him in his weird life do you
know I mean he didn't control your
oxygen spire anything no did he like you
know he could have killed me yeah just
yeah just like drunk drooling away and
suddenly all you hear is God's gonna get
you and your so right now you've got a
bit of a brief back to the dead granddad
yeah so all right so we're well off in a
joking but you know the whole thing with
your dad and watching him go through
that yeah how how was that just
generally like has he is he sort of okay
and that now and that is he crouched
yeah but he sounds these like he's our
best mate so I've noticed that about you
yeah so to see him cry that [__] you up
done it and like and then
yeah and then exactly what you were
saying there would be points where it's
like I would I would be kind and people
down we shouldn't cry yeah you don't
know but then there would also be the
other side of things where I wouldn't
cry they'll be like he's crying do I
look like I don't care thank you yeah
why aren't i crying or can i have a good
time at any point yeah and it [__] up
your emotions because you don't know how
just how to fail like and genuinely i've
been thinking about making a video about
dealing with grief because like for this
very reason because when you lose
someone there's no set menu of what
you're supposed to do know your care and
no one beats themselves up about am i
enough i made her too much what's normal
here and the truth is this [__] no
normal not all [__] I'll tell you I
went to my granddad's funeral went to
the wake had a few beers went back to
Norwich and went on right yeah
and it was like vomit I was in my soup
yeah and I was like what am i doing and
it's the first time ever in my life that
I've told people no and they've asked me
for a photo and I was they were like why
of interferer I don't feel a threat and
they must have a people why the [__] you
out that's like because I'm getting
steaming [__] it's wrong yeah because
I feel like [__] I couldn't justify my
weather that's it to myself lots of
people go out after funerals though it's
totally not is it see I don't know so
that video would be you know like some
people some people it's a celebration of
life type vibe and some people just want
to get shit-faced you feel that that was
made for one of mines we had one of my
weird moments with a funeral remember
I've talked about because in a little
bit I was at a Funeral family funeral
with me cousin was there me younger
cousin he was like me little brother
growing up sort of thing yeah and he
came and I like look the mods like
you're off your [__] tits like on
drugs yeah I can say a [__] mile off
and he always loved it loved these drugs
and that so I was like I was like look
mate we're a [__] family funeral
someone's died and I'm a talking to him
like clear as day I remember the pub I
remember where we son everything I won't
be like if you don't [__] quit this
[__] like because because he was an
extremist I knew he wasn't just taking a
little bit here and there I knew he was
taking it like
the limit I was I this is gonna be your
[__] funeral and shut [__] two
years they are at his funeral I like a
mama bein that his funeral in the [__]
Pope but you're like this is where I
[__] told them like this is what was
gonna happen
it's so [__] Wow Mendel verse really
that's quite tragic though yeah that was
that was the worst funeral to be honest
with ya obviously funerals are generally
sad but when someone hasn't even had
kids
Mariota gone to have a life and then
it's over before it even they've
realized that but like he had so much
Ireland he was 23 that losses like yeah
he was a DJ he dated like the biggest
club sidon at Newcastle when in London
de Jade there like he he was one of
those people who could just pick
anything up and [__] master it like
he was right in a bike before I wasn't
he was two years younger than me like he
just had this Knick Knack she's wasted
potential as I got this image of
life-size you Brian now but on a tiny
little boy so I think I'll make a peon
like let's just say I was like nine and
he was seven or whatever and he comes
[__] peddling around the corner and
nor fear whatsoever and I'm like oh me
train and wheels I mean little [__]
cousins just short for you yeah I
instantly was like [__] training
wheels off now like I can't be having
this but like he did that with
everything like everything so I'll just
now when I go it was [__] gravesite
I'm always a bit like I think obviously
I think yeah he was a funny YouTube and
he knew I was getting into YouTube but I
was just like I think of how much like
he could have done and they're the worst
mmm bittersweet like when someone's died
and their forties and fifties it's
really sad it is too young but if
they've managed to have a life have a
family and do things this there's an
ongoing story then it's it hasn't fully
ended for me yeah we're here meet just
don't yeah I mean that is really [__]
hard yeah it is the potential isn't it
the waste of potential had so much and
yeah that's pretty that's pretty dark
mate I also think we do we new part in
England we're terrible
talking about death we're really bad as
a culture of talking about just emotions
in general emotions but then that really
impacts on us talking about like loss of
life and those and it tends to be that
the only time we tend to talk about it
is when we're talking about cancer or
these sorts of things and people talk
what I put saying harsh respective
doesn't in here puts it in harsher
perspective there's a very weird
reaction very few people who will then
go I'm gonna go and live every day to
the fullest hmm and we're on it's not
theirs and I don't know things like
YouTube in you know in Instagram and
Twitter help that or sort of put more of
a veneer between you and oh I think it
definitely hinders it yeah and does what
so hinders that that feeling that you
need all that feeling that I feel like I
would need to go out and fulfill the
potential all the time we we are not
numb but I'm trying to find the right
word for I'll be confused as to what you
mean like as a culture I think we can
where we distance ourselves from
engaging with loss and like yeah I I get
a lot of dm's
like about that about people dealing
with the loss and sadness and stuff like
that but when you when you look at your
Twitter timeline it's very little about
that isn't it so publicly people tend to
hold back yeah I see I thought you meant
a little bit more on like just the
grieving side of things I'd say it's
it's so hard to grieve when you have to
keep up a social profile and people you
have all these people watching you all
the time you you need these big breaks
and sometimes you need breaks bigger
than YouTube will allow you to have
otherwise your channel dies and and
every youtuber goes for it I think is
when when you're not uploading even if
you're just being lazy you're constantly
thinking I need to have an upload soon
because this is everyday that every
second that it expires is you becoming
more irrelevant as the pause would say
so it's just play on your mind fully
yeah all the time so even when you're
not uploading you're thinking about it
and if you've got other things going on
in your life and you're still trying to
upload and to a certain extent with with
me on Twitter I'm kind of playing a
character as well although I post what I
believe I hire
for everyone's lunch lines in there but
then as I was saying to you a minute ago
I when I was going for all that and I'm
not using that as an excuse because I
could have easily taken a different row
and been that just fine but I thought I
found myself getting genuinely angry
which hindered a lot of things so like
the will any beef the famous will an EP
that everyone brings up that was that
was my fault
like that was me that's me from a place
of being so angry that just in myself
that when he's tweeting something that I
didn't know that it was it was a joke
like I just didn't I didn't I didn't
read him so I didn't have any time to
read into it and it was it was me
everyone knows what it's about it's
about the hello world thing I tweeted
about it I'm as I'm tweeting about it
I'm constantly thinking what are people
gonna come at you with well not so much
I kind of feel like a broken record it
because youtubers are [__] up again
and you're on the defense automatically
so yeah so I'm tweeting about it and I'm
like a hundred-pound from eating great
that's that's [__] and then I see wills
tweeted have a day off and because we DM
every now and then I thought we could
have just the end that like and then I
find it funny now looking back from
where it was like ass is funny and I
should have come back with an equally
funny comeback and I usually would do
that but because I just felt a felt of
it as a bit of a kick because I was like
and then I think I retorted with like
well you would have you would have done
spiraled out of control
yeah I said he would have made a video
about that had he not been friends with
with those youtubers which I believe now
I still believe but then I went on to
really be silly and I mentioned it in a
video and I thought to myself I didn't
need to mention in the video because
whether or not I believe like like
you've done things I disagree with
you've done thing I've done plenty that
you disagree with right but we have this
kind of level of bonding is in there
when they all made like and especially
is like will came onto my podcast that I
started up when it was [__] it was in a
basement yeah and he didn't need to do
that yeah like so I I owed him a bit
more respect I should have left at
weight even if I was a bit angry in my
way I could have kept that up it's only
a [__] twee they'll worry but then to
make a video and this in like that
it was kind of like taking it too far
and as soon as I uploaded it I was like
I didn't get rid any real backlash from
it but I just felt bad in myself I don't
think you'd only thing is you didn't
from my point of view was met with both
ears it was a [__] awkward - oh yeah
[__] and I've never ever disliked him
ever even even when he made by working
with him even many when he made the
comeback video I didn't think it was
very good as well I didn't think the
points in it without strong I think at
that point so from the way I viewed the
whole situation as when you didn't take
him the right way yes will says [__]
like that to me all the time an [__]
yeah he's like you loved him for a sort
of thing yeah I knew it's easy certainly
I seen that now and someone could be
sitting there and saying you're only
saying that cause everything you just
talked about I didn't feel that you were
in a good space then right and you took
it the wrong way because of how you were
feeling generally and for somebody who's
constantly commentating and taking the
piss and trying to be a comedian I
should have always taken that as a job
like always and that I've had but I have
way worse stuff said to me by people
that I know genuinely hate me so when it
mate saying something like I should have
just come back with something way but as
I said people say now like oh what's
this be for willing me off about you've
squashed it I apologized to will months
ago in the DM z-- and I'm thankful that
he took it that worked well and because
he is an he's a nice guy we love we can
joke about him as much he's very nice
but when I get all these comments all
the time saying have a day off mate
that's fine that's funny
I see the funny side of it now keep them
coming I do not get but what I do care
about is when people are like watch this
with like what's happening with a well
Andy beef because I think I've always
ignored it because it's like I don't
want there to be any even when he made
that whole video custom me up I was
still watching his con I'd still watch
his next up though like no I I was well
aware of that at the time but I think
when it's a little bit like rap music
for me and you too in this I like and
skilled there assists and then when one
says something about the other the other
one then feels the need to retaliate
even if there's no actual
problem it's almost like to me our view
you as the two best commentary guys in
that field right so you have to respond
it's almost like he had to respond and
yeah as soon as you put on video it's
like right I've got to come back with a
truck now June arms yeah yeah so it as
much as and then it looked like Willie
is thinking like a rapper would think of
what everything I can possibly say yeah
you know I yeah and it's not even about
do I like or dislike this guy I've got a
sure what I am here to everyone else
yeah very much like a rock world yes
partly but you were feeling a little bit
like ah I should have a day off it not
like have a day off I should be changing
things up a little bit so when you then
heard that from someone that you respect
or someone you like yeah it sort of
strikes a bit of a nerve yeah yeah
hundred percent it was a combination of
two things the first thing that I've
already already spoke about is I just
[__] hate the world so anyone that
writes through it I don't but in that
moment in that moment it was a [__] off
like I said it and it and it just
happened to be in yeah and and then
there is another case of this constant
battle that we have and probably me more
so the most where it's like I'm churning
out the same stuff and and it's getting
boring to me so I tried to think what
what is getting to other people and then
and then yeah you hit the nail on the
head when he says it it's kind of like
I'm so aware like when you said it when
you get a comment that's already been
playing on your mind I'm so aware that
that's at you can't tell me anything I
don't already know that's just it's just
like that you I have nothing really to
say other than just [__] off just [__]
just [__] off like alright so I taught
you get where you're coming from
I've been there yeah lately yeah you've
definitely seemed in a much better place
mentally in me anyway yeah I'm the
outside looking in you started getting
into boxing yeah
and you know doing all these other
ventures let's talk about the boxing
first you were like heavily critical
obviously like it's your job to be all
the the YouTube box and thing and you
made all the good job so I expect you
yeah but all of a sudden you're like I'm
actually kinda like than this yeah yes
or not
yeah what was it how have you ended up
going into a [__] boxing gym all of a
sudden so first of all I'm the biggest
hypocrite on YouTube I'm very very
self-aware but yeah I think when it
first came about I was like silly
they're they're youtubers like come on
like it was it was more so like I don't
know what I should as you said I've done
a lot of growing up right I feel like
when a youtuber throws their hat into
the ring so to speak in a new in a new
genre they should always be applauded
right because they're not actually
hurting anyone they're just trying
something new like I think higher size
music is absolutely terrible right but I
sure that's my opinion right I don't
dislike him as a person he's never done
anything to me
but I admire the [__] out of him right
because and I care that may be
hypocritical of things I've said about
him on YouTube when he said about the
mental health things I'm quick to jump
on these things but just because I don't
think he's good at one thing I would I
would still never be able to do that and
I would never be able to do it any
better
so I admire the [__] out of that and
like there's is again it's like MIT me
so I got off an archery video there's no
point that might be the best archery
video I've ever made but me snagging it
off because I don't like archery it
doesn't make sense yeah so what was the
saying so with the boxing thing I was
very what point did it change for you I
watched I was very much like people come
up to me on a night out before the well
er ksi fight and they'd say who do you
thinks gonna win and I'd be this [__]
edgy character going don't really care
about it or stupids just two youtubers
and when it was on I was the first
person watching it right and I'm sat
there in the bed right in a pot noodle
while these two youtubers are absolutely
smashing it right even Joe who got beat
the [__] up yeah he's in there [__]
doing it right and he's laughed at
himself loads since then I have nothing
but admiration for them people so since
I will always tweet jokes about the
YouTube community right but just
slagging them off that actually trying
something new doesn't make any sense and
it didn't
down by how I felt anymore so when the
so when the bill that was happening to
the recent fight I was all for it I was
really involved in it people come up to
me and asked what I think and I'll give
them my opinion I'll speak to him all
day long I was lucky enough to be in
your box to Borat like I was I was I was
involved did get you a ticket for the
fight but you were busy at a gig I was
at Reading Festival yes I would next
time Jack you won't get that invited I
would have I would have loved to have
been there I would have done and Anna
and I so you were watching it after the
fact William yeah I wanted to watch it
when I was there I wanted to stream it
like people were in the crowd I was
watching Kendrick Lamar at the time I
don't know much about Kendrick Lamar but
I saw there was an this group around me
at all recognized me know knew I was and
they just kept coming up to me every
minute what's the score yes this whole
thing and I was like just cuz I'm a
youtuber doesn't mean I [__] it
oh I get a YouTube censors of telling me
that case I was winning the first two
Logan's win the first but I was so like
I'm watching this and I was just
thinking I'm watching this everyone's
going nuts but me and this group around
me had just focused on what's going on
and yeah I just sort of fell in love
with it there and three weeks ago three
or four weeks ago I there's a guy called
the halal ham yeah he messaged me out
the blue and was like Jonah fight me on
the undercard and instantly I was like
and I know he used the box and stuff but
I was like get on that and the car would
be good so I said yeah and then
obviously you think about it you think
the height the weight none of it makes
sense and then Josh Peters called me out
and instantly I was like cuz I'm so
quite self-deprecating anyway I was like
he'll he'll beat me up he will be Mia
but this could be quite funny I don't
know like I think you were very very
decently matched and in pretty much the
same height I think he seeks for I'm six
million American inch taller than you
yeah yeah and he called me out and I was
like I sat there for an hour and I think
and right and he said he knew the right
people that can make that happen
let's just do it and then since that day
something in me has changed completely
and I have I I can't box right I do not
know what I'm doing I'm only four weeks
in for [__] sake but every single day
I'm training I'm eating well I'm so much
happier and I think [__] this is what
these youtubers have been there and the
whole time that this is their their
life's gray and I feel like I don't
really care what my numbers are doing
online now i have i have actually
something better to do I've not gone out
drinking partying I was doing that every
other fun every [__] weekend like it
was a problem so I feel like it's only a
positive thing you feel and difference
in physicality affects you as well like
you you do look a job are chard knows
what we're asking your girlfriend must
have noticed the vent
it's only it's only been a month but my
body is changing quickly you are you're
a lean
tall dude so it probably won't take long
for things to change yeah and and it's
it's it's my mind that changed the most
I actually now find myself defending
these youtubers when I'm watching when
I'm reading articles and they come in
they're just - they're not boxers I
don't think any either of them are
saying they're boxers I know KS eyes got
bigger aspirations to go on and he
probably could but I then now find
myself trying to yeah what's that it's a
bit like when that bad one and the Power
Rangers rejoined the Power Rangers so
it's the Green Ranger and then you
became the white wide entry yeah that's
basically what you are dressed so yeah
for me I don't know like at the time
when I was going out on the pistol
because you said like you like the booze
and all that and you get in the habit of
doing that and it becomes its startup so
anything like that sort of habit it
starts off fun and then at some point
after a while you're kind of like is
this still fun you know is this really
what I wanted yeah and then like lately
I've gone on a [__] diet and started
doing cardio and stuff like that more
and I'm like yeah I just I don't know
this swimming in my head telling me like
alright so I might be sitting they leave
to come and say move your ass you fat
[__] but like yeah pretty much like
that's exactly what it feels like we're
not made to sit on the couch or sit
around getting pissed all the time like
yeah that's fun like every now and then
like in small doses and stuff like one
night a week two nights or fair enough
but like it did to the degree I did it
at one point like bad for us like so
it's also when you start having the same
night out over and over again oh and
it's that you start to hear the same
songs you know that are mr. Brightside
zone again maybe I don't know how
accurate that is yeah and you really
don't I go to the same place in Norwich
yeah every week yeah well I did and they
have the same it's a propaganda night
they have the same playlist on song for
song so a song will come out I'll be
this one next and it is I go out for
this obviously the same bouncers the
same people I have people coming up to
me
third it's their third time they've
asked me for a photo right that's fine
Norwich there's not many youtubers so
it's been like Newcastle for me yes
you're like very recognizable yeah yeah
one person maybe if I'm popping in and
out in Norwich it's it's because it is a
small that same review in new classic
it's like it's all the time and I kind
of I kind of because they were obviously
above 18 and I could stand there and
have a chat with them I thought that was
kind of reason why III enjoyed it I
enjoyed the attention so I was going out
all the time party and doing all this
stuff and then it writes off your next
few days yeah cuz you're yeah you're
hungover yeah and I've seen that in
stuff stories yeah okay and you're
eating [__] and you know they're
anything but now I've basically what I
did at the start this month when I
decided to make this change I didn't
know how seriously I was going to take
this I'm sure I've shot I'm shocked
myself
I know it's still early day so I don't
want to end up looking silly in two
months if I've stopped but I'm pretty
sad and I've got it locked in my head
now first thing I did was when I said I
would stop in I've arranged a pub crawl
for the end of this month because it's
like I can't stop it altogether because
ultimately I do enjoy it but that's my
goal and then once once I do that you
have to do that we reset right and we
can we do that we go again oh yeah
otherwise sad I stopped drinking for six
months once and I was I was doing a lot
of believe it or not I was a lot lighter
I was about nine stone lighter than what
I am now I hadn't discovered
weightlifting at that point I was in the
cardio or only so in the same day I
would swim run and like do some of the
form of like rowing or tennis or
something they are on an a just to get
everything going yeah I was like
obsessively exercising and I remember at
the end of the six months I was like now
I need a [__] drink now I need a deal
like a whole [__] we learnt it by
that point oh you learnt it by that yeah
I could run I could do like a six mile
run as if it was nothing like and
I was doing I don't know was it
Milan huh I could do a mile and a half
in under ten minutes like I was I was
like fast like because these long legs
at the time I had that [__] Usain
Bolt like [__] stride and I was not
carrying any way any other way I got now
but then I remember when I smelled a
cannon lager I was like [__] mate it
smelled like petrol because I hadn't
hadn't touched a drop in sick it was
like the alcohol was so overpowering I
mean I was like whoa yeah does not smell
like how it used to mmm no it [__]
before cars old piss and also you're
doing so much cardio that you've got
very little muscle and fat in your body
to be able to deal with if are short a
picture of people they'd be like that
they leave in the same person like
because then after I'd got bored of
cordial as I am going to try with now
and I was just a natural weightlifter
and that's when I was like ah [__] this
is what I'm made for and then I started
eating more and I was like protein and
anything I'll go on then I can have a
burger that's protein and then before I
knew it I was like lifting really heavy
but also eating [__] the nice way my
whisk in came from then had the death
and a family and then I had like six
months off the gym but then they'd eaten
cat and before I knew it I'm like 20
I was nearly 25 stone at one point but
not purely muscle no I was just thick
and like like I was I was [__] and
muscular at the same time I know I'm
still like that now to a degree but like
I was really thick at that point but
yeah the other day there's also honey a
gown on a diet I'm starting to die
today's the day get on the skills find
out where the [__] you are and I
obviously know from the Logan and JJ a
fight they were 185 pounds and they're
about Logan's my height or maybe maybe
an inch shorter they were 185 pounds I
get on the scales
312 pounds I was like I'm [__] like
130 [__] pounds heavier than Logan
Pole that's more than you have CPM
perimeter
I can't even compete in the USA are that
I'm over the weight limit basically they
fight muscle now those yeah did you feel
when you saw that number relieved
because I feel a five hundred I fail I
feel so my heaviest was three hundred
and forty pound was the heaviest I've
ever been in my life so I feel eerily no
I thought that was just when I was
weightlifting but also sitting on the
couch eating all day
Rikishi's 400 pounds do you know what I
mean like that's and I think we're he
she's a big guy
god rest her soul twelve right I feel
heavy and you're still so dynamic and I
watch it you don't walk like a guy who's
312 pounds
you don't run like a guy's the engine
time this is the thing people give me so
much [__] but I'm actually an athlete
like I know that that sounds silly it
does sort like I've got good a main to
body movement like I move like a short
ass and like when we did the NFL videos
I was quick like I was quicker than
[__] Joel from cheeky sport in the
[__] little trial that we did draws a
[__] fast Laden I think naturally
gifted in that but anyway so I was like
I feel [__] heavy I feel fat I feel
that was [__] I'm gonna get in shape so
this is my thing now are you gonna be
going to sort of Weight Watchers or Glen
there I think my brain is the first
thing I thought this but you'd pull
there some confidence boosting you look
fantastic
how many sins with Evy yeah you know
Siemens low calorie these days yeah
is what Brian yeah don't know that one
down like don't worry about nice so I
saw it called your this week and like
because I've always done weightlifting
but the some ago called you that just
feels different if it's better for you
you get that runner's high
this oh it's amazing yeah yeah yeah it's
incredible
yeah I'm not is that although do you
still do the intense walk I mentioned
this on a podcast once and I was like
intense walking burns fat not muscle and
two really good for you like walking
quickly because you haven't got that in
impact on your body so your muscles tend
to not be affected by it right and
Lawrence was like maybe some of me Jill
well okay my story [__] right still
send me Joe well as videos when Joe's on
the treadmill just doing an intense walk
they'll still forward it to me and go
and he's doing it again wait hang on so
Jonas Joe was saying you do there you
can do is walking so when you don't bend
your legs you sort of runs no but it
burns fat and not as much muscle as what
running would for example yes no it's
not so much the actual it's just the
concept of saying an intense walk yeah
to me it's like an oxymoron yeah how you
all been you pretty much nailed it for
the record yeah like I'm very I'm like a
[__] grasshopper yeah yeah like I'm
very my strides are huge and I'll stride
out when I'm going down the street yeah
what a weird podcaster says yeah it's
like yeah I mean mostly bad you're gonna
be getting in the ring probably with
Josh Pia's
well probably I don't know because I've
heard on the grapevine from the powers
that they the
Cass believes boxing here is what you
heard on the Griffon and I've heard that
he that Josh isn't a big enough Pole
that's what I've heard from people I've
heard and this could just be the person
that I'm speaking to could just be bow
and smoke I don't know I've heard that I
was I was on the list of like potent
potentials and I don't know how much if
this is true or not this could all be
absolute bollocks but you're more in
this world than I am I've heard that
when it when the previous fight happened
because don't get me wrong I could just
literally just be a [__] nobody
youtuber that's just polka my head
through the wall gun I could be on there
under code JJ can watch it go there's
not a [__] chance right but I've
heard there would be you yet JJ chose
all the undercard boys right so when it
happens in America it's all Logan the
chooses it right and it's gonna be it's
just it's just that it's just - no but I
got told that I was on a standby list
but I would have to I would have to put
pay my own flights and accommodation
which is fine but they said that Josh
wasn't a big enough Pole life is about
to be on the undercard to be on the
undercard but because I'm gonna
subscribers he's got more than me but I
guess because I'm so outspoken people
would love to see me get beat up it's
not just that Josh would understand
where I'm coming from with this is
relevancy in terms of or you're very
well known especially in the UK because
of what you've become
Josh isn't as outspoken as you his
contents very different easy youtubers
friends
yeah that's what it is so it's always
Comedy Central's - I think it's
something I'm saying that right that's
alright it's got decent delivery for
sure
a bit like myself like there's a lot of
youtubers with the same amount of
subscribers as me they aren't as well
known as maybe out of the types of
videos of me in them yes I mean I can't
I can't guarantee I I'm fully confident
I could get you
yeah yeah well if you can I would I
would fight pretty much anyone as long
as it's not yes yeah yeah or someone
mentor or Mike Bisping yeah Mandy
Holyfield in a retirement making that
you in I would fight any of their
Casper's alfea's like and I've got way
more to lose like a rumble with those
guys so you they come in you just have
to knock them down then the next ones
running down the route yeah
customer made a video about new one boy
and then he deleted it and and I
remember thinking to myself oh no you
done there yeah I've met before he seems
like a nice guy so love what but I view
you as just going to be honest yeah I
view you as a really talented
[__] and what you do there isn't
anyone better there's people on your
level but not I wouldn't say anyone
better it it when it comes to brick and
someone down in a funny way I have
always said you're the guy so when
someone tries to go against you who's
from the old school where they're not
versed in putting that level of work and
effort into a video and they just have
to sort of hi guys yeah with all due
respect the Kasbah I just knew this was
going to end badly for him what was it
like for you watching that video I I got
a tweet I was at a premiere at the time
don't you know for ready player one and
I got a tweet saying that Casper was
making a response I was like [__] like
okay it's first time this has really
happened where someone's responded and
you feel about yourself in that moment
because they've never done that you know
nervous because I was like this could
end me he's got what seven eight million
subscribers so this could M me but we'll
see what happens
I was pretty confident in the reasons
that I called him out in the first place
so I what I kind of had that fallback
not cuz imma when Logan mentioned me I
was like jackpot [__] I've done
it right yeah but the point is is you
know clearly broke through it or that in
the past they wanted to keep you down
yeah mentioning him or any validates and
further let's say after he doesn't exist
and now all of a sudden you're relevant
enough to that for them to feel like
this is our the York
a genuine threat at this point because
you're seeing so much that yeah it
didn't ever really bother me that much
it wasn't one of these like MJ MGK
things where like Eminem's mentioned him
too that validates him I genuinely was
never bothered I'm sort of like an empty
key right now actually yeah yeah it's
not winning me over I watch his
interview sorry the takeaway from The
Breakfast Club I'm sure you're actually
coming across as legit he works yeah I
agree with that but so you saw you watch
the response video oh yeah yeah so I
yeah what only reason that I was I was a
slightly actresses I thought he could
absolutely ruin me if he picked me apart
and picked the right things because
there's a lot out there there is and he
didn't and when I watched it I kind of
felt like his response was better than
anything I could have ever hoped oh yeah
because it was so poor he played into
your hands full
it was so bad and the fact that he was
sat with Josh it was like oh come on it
was and then when he deleted it the next
day it was just not even it was almost
like this is car crash hear me you have
to live live and die by your words and
he's just yeah it can in defensive cuss
but it's just not him it's not and it
was him try to know you at your own game
yeah and if you if he was gonna come in
you know do damage to your sort of who
you are yeah he had to do his style and
I guess played the moral high ground a
little bit is the best thing you could
have done at that point and instead of
trying to do the funny one-liners and
stuff like that you know yeah John said
that when he came onto my podcast I
wasn't really he says he go I go online
I say things like nasty things but when
he sees me in personal not really like
that I was like well that's a good thing
you'll basically telling everyone he's
actually really alright in person yeah
so that's why that's another reason why
I think it'll be fun if I get involved
in this YouTube boxing thing because I
will whether or not I get beaten the
[__] out of in the first round I will
win the fight before the fight if that
makes sense
no you're coming to McGregor this at the
start on 100%
athough myself josh versus chuck me
doing like an in the middle interview
with you guys apiece yeah josh is funny
I've gotta give credit josh is a funny
guy and I know that you sold both say
some hilarious and you'll I think
embrace the spirit of what this would be
about really so that's why I warned to
logan throughout the whole thing yeah
because he very much came at it from an
entertainers point of the eighty and
although yeah he was trying a little bit
to be Conor McGregor and whatnot I think
it's hard not to be because Connors at
the top of that game and if you're
taking as we said at the start the
podcast if you're taking inspiration
from someone like that you're gonna be
and I really want a Logan because he he
made it fun for me to watch JJ's JJ for
me was the athlete who knows what he's
doing and was really [__] impressive
and from an amateur's he inspired me to
want to try boxing but Logan inspired me
to try and up my entertainment game and
I think that's what I realized when as
it went on yeah was like when you first
see Logan do in the [__] forest video
you're like this guy is so out of touch
yeah so not self-aware and but then as
time went on like you said I think
because I watched your analysis in the
gloves are off
you don't realize why he is quite self
away actually yeah just he did make the
huge mistake but he gets what where he
is now yeah yeah me I think would be
sick if he did it cuz like no one can
then say oh well you know he's actually
frightened of these guys and he's just
sitting in his shed [__] talkin [__]
yeah get in the ring no one can [__] and
say anything yeah I'd love to do it do
well I kind of don't want you to talk it
down too much because I want you to get
in that mentality who could actually win
this well you're [__] through you're
a big old boy so late you're definitely
gonna be capable of something and could
do something not just walk in and go
well yeah and then just because that
because obviously that is a way I'd play
it yeah because I don't have any self
belief in the ring but I know I can do
all the other priam [__] but just
just last thing I'll say on it is my
family my dad side they're all from a
boxing background
so my cousin was a professional boxer
her name was genuinely rocky not making
the heart really key Dean Wow yeah
that's a genuine thing they have their
own gym it's the bee's knees and I can
use it whenever I've got the hole and
it's one two one two
[__] you Joshua uses that then Power
Rangers Megazord across the ring really
throw someone off though wouldn't know
two punches coming from the city
this guy must really know what he's
doing with two balls me honestly they
won't be yeah so I've got that trade
we're so good luck for that yeah so I've
got all all that so I'm gonna be too bad
if I'm if I put myself African name this
is cricket player youtubers made Wow
he's already doing it's funny Khan
scoffed but what's your channel me
you're also doing one thing that really
fascinates me is when youtubers
completely step out of their bubble yeah
and you're doing a magazine yeah just
like that really fascinates me like
different forms of do media is really
interesting right just that like you
know I'm only I'm only in doing videos
yeah why what why why why do magazine
interesting how because I'm not I'm
often I'm often writing blogs about
satirical little pieces and they don't
go anywhere
yes I don't have anywhere for them to
say I think you're I mean it's not do
you think you could write it but I do
you have a passion for of all arrivin is
the right and yeah always I've written
sitcoms
I've written love I've written stand-up
shows I've never taken anywhere all my
videos are scripted mm-hmm every single
one I don't say every single one but 99%
of them yeah I love that side side of
things so that's what I want to do and I
want to make I know it's I know it's
very dodgy waters Jack Maitre D'
submerge
that's very badly you never done much I
have I've done bits and bobs I've done
ironic pieces I seen that a little book
in that you do yeah yeah not much mate
yeah yeah in response to Ollie White's
what is up t-shirts no much Matt was
quite good yeah Ali now different yeah
have you met him before I'm out before
you met him before YouTube didn't hear I
know he had a little experience of them
before YouTube I think yeah tell us
I saw him on a shoot that I won't know
whether she was but he was being a piece
of talent on the shoot and I honestly I
also would preface this by saying I
think one experience can sum up a
character yeah
didn't particularly look like he valued
being there rather he valued the
position he gotten into yeah and it was
something that at the time as someone
who had like no follower to you know no
followers mm Paolo is something like
that and was really like trying to get
into that space when I saw that I felt
like he was taking it for granted
yeah really annoyed me so I got my
backup and so I've never really given
him the opportunity I can't be useful he
was a bit of a he had a bit of an
attitude indifferent some of the people
are a bit like he's a bit hard to work
with like we're not particularly enjoy
it and I remember something I grabbed
that with both hands and I really love
to do what he's doing and that always
annoys me is that was like a good
springboard for him that he didn't
understand really different the whole
situation that's what annoyed me was I
felt like if you could give an
opportunity you should always take it
with both hands
yeah and not take that for granted I've
heard a lot of similar stories about
about that but everything that fully
summarizes him obviously can go I mean
he's got great relationship with the
brother he's got a great relationship
with his family and
you know it's not it's not his fault bit
here's where he is I just I didn't bite
that vibe and he didn't make me dislike
Casper didn't they didn't make me
dislike Joe I know mom's got their
position it's probably people that like
you that don't like me though I will
it's usually the other way around
doesn't look like neither do my ears but
everyone's got their opinions by Sarah
times where I feel like it there some
people talk to me about you and they go
yeah but whatever he's a bit of a [__]
Denis or whatever and I'm like no you
just don't know him hmm and then I think
is it the same with all my family just
stopping in Europe and the thing is
calls at 3 o'clock in the morning I will
pick them up because I'm just so groggy
you know it's I can be quite hard to
work with the times though apparently
because I all those people who work with
us who say they're a bit worried about
my reactions to things and stuff
perfectionist and you you want
everything to go so well huh that
sometimes I feel like you can it can
swing the other way where it you you
then you then go this isn't not none of
this is what I wanted and the problem is
in YouTube and I was saying this the
other day because I've had this
experience when trying to make the last
video that turned out [__] anyway like I
had so many shooter I thought this isn't
exactly right well this isn't what I
want it to be what one was a the one we
made about like the media and ksi and
most like really good it was nicely
edited but what the problem with it was
I felt like it on TV
they'll make space for a test shoot
they'll make space for let's script this
in time on YouTube there's like a get it
out get it out get it out get it out and
I sort of got caught in that we need to
get out rather than enjoying the process
of it what you don't like it it just
doesn't go to the level and Brian I both
agree it didn't go to the level that him
and I both set the standard for and I
felt like I'd sort of let myself down
like Brian down in a sense and we'd had
that honest conversation me and him go
back and forth so like if there's if
there's videos that I make or he makes
on X or AZ that's sort of Lawrence Bruns
X or pretty much yeah we just feed back
to each other
yeah I'm really honest do you know Tommy
and the one of the problems that I've
got is I've Lawrence is more talented
than me
I've got a more of because I've got I've
come from a totally different background
I've got a more practical approach to
everything so Lawrence comes at it from
an artistic side where he's learned
things that I've got no [__] clue
about and I'm coming in from this this
is the process I want it and my process
is a lot more like streamlined so I just
get [__] done yeah which is what enabled
me to get where I am was basically like
not a tenth of his talent you know I
mean so you'll achieve a sees the match
and yeah I don't know but we come we
come at things from a we're good for
each other
because we give each other honest [__]
critiques you know and I watch the last
video I was like I know you're capable
of 10 names more than that that's just
if people might look at me like that's
harsh as [__] but it's like fair but you
want when you want the best for each
other yeah you need to be that way with
each other as far as I'm concerned and I
add that's fair if anyone else asked me
the honest truth about their YouTube
channels I'd be the same way but with
him it's were more even we can be more
honest you know he's that's and I think
that is part of for me what production
is as well you need to be able to
honestly evaluate someone not without
ego but without without taking it so
personally it hurts you it does hurt me
obviously sometimes I hear Brian said I
was fine [__] video the video hated it I
was like fantastic so but I apologized
afterwards I don't you say I'm sorry if
I was quite overly critical it's just
like how I am at times I get I'm
invested in YouTube I love it mmm
relevant yeah then becomes you have to
be then be able to walk away from that
and go I appreciate your evaluation and
I'll take on board and rather than oh my
god I'm so upset that Brian's said
something that I'm worse with meself so
much on my own stuff than I am on anyone
like even if I think the video is good I
never get that high anymore I used to
get when I did a really good video I
never get it I'm always like right God
next like when we did the last video but
is that because your standards have gone
higher because you got more subscribers
or no nice I don't know what is I
thought we I work with a guy who people
may not know called geo on me I think
you've met you was shot he shot my
device bug alright so me and geo were
together pretty much every week on
everything and he had he had it with me
and like the lots of [__] genius
but we did that last video we put it out
I was I was happy with it but then I I
never take time to be like wow that's a
good video I'm happy with that
oh I exist the one with the only messed
up on is this the one where you add the
only marriage stuff on and y'all know
this was the one what I really thought
of the look and Paul Kerr sigh okay
heavily at like 40-minute mini docs
aisle right long shoot like yeah we put
a lot of effort into that Geo gruff that
he's our stuff on it but what I'm saying
is I don't have that
it's not like I'm criticizing what
Laurence is doing and then sitting back
and stuff and going [__] hey that's
brilliant I'm amazing if anything once I
think something is up the standard it
goes out and then it's on to the next
thing that I never ever admire what I'm
doing I just criticize and move on
criticize and move on I'm never like
impressed with meself
oh yeah which can sometimes be it's
unhealthy probably but you can tell me I
know how to get through life maybe it
does build up some your frustration and
if you did sit back maybe every now and
again and go I really enjoyed yeah it's
weird I can't I don't know because I
feel the same but then you're caught you
do a lot better content than I do but ya
know I think I think I think your
standard is just getting higher and
higher
obviously you bet you're bound to have
the odd porush video yeah but yeah I
think overall your content is getting
higher and higher it's just because
you're there's more people for you to
feel the need to impress now you're a
brand you know yourself that everyone
knows well I think you don't think your
content justifies how much you have like
when it really does it written and when
people bang on about Dave Dorrit Shane
Dawson Casey nice that I want to be in
that group of youtubers yeah you're not
that you're not and yeah you're just as
good but you're parallel to them you
have your own thing but that's what I'm
saying is I want I want to be spoken
about in that way of truth he's got a
documentary coming out like you don't
realize that how how much you are though
you don't like so when I when I did my
podcast and I will in the future do it
again uh-huh it's not - III enjoy it and
and you're a big inspiration of that
which I don't think you realize you are
at the top of your of this game in the
UK you are so you have the Joe Rogan you
have the true Geordie podcast
you'd be surprised that when I go out in
Norwich as I've said people recognize me
all the time
you that you wouldn't recommend you
wouldn't realize how many people
recognize me because I've been on your
podcast
you wouldn't know I've done videos with
with lots of youtubers believe honor
you're one of the ones they asked about
the most so you are you're a big
character in the game and you don't
realize it so that's probably why you're
never happy enough with the content you
like next one because you don't realize
just how good it is when you upload a
podcast people when I uploaded my
podcasts there was problems with the
sound the visual the guests weren't
right I went a great host all this stuff
we have all getting problems but but
you're you're so good at it like you
both complement each other so well I
guarantee when you make these when we're
doing this now could be a [__] two
hour-long podcast the whole time I've
been thinking the majority of people
will be listening to the whole thing
because that's that's how invested they
are in you me they might just get to the
bit right call alfie account do you not
I mean
yeah a lot of the things you're saying I
don't realize because I think it's just
embedded in my brain and never feel good
I thought me and I'd like me in that
like sometimes I rape meself and I'll
rate a certain bit of content or
whatever
I feel like ya deserve to be but
generally that's like a momentary thing
and for the most part I'm like neatly
about any computer so it's a personality
flaw but it's one that sort of kind of
works to my advantage because clearly
this never end and striving to be this
fictional place that I want to be in my
head where I'm spoken about with these
creators I think you need to be told
more often that you are though because
then I think doesn't work you know yeah
I know and I'm the same I'm the same
yeah you you feel like you're not good
enough and you're trying to justify that
you there's a reason I'm here like I'm
justifying it but that can be your
downfall as well because you are you're
so much better than Shannon Briggs yeah
but then when you're on your channel
saying ah I can do that I can do that if
people aren't watching you thinking oh
he thinks he can do it
I thought the opposite I thought you
were going what why is he doing it not
mate like and you were trying to be on
that level you're already on that level
and you're far but surpass that when you
can well when you're saying it when you
did that head to head and this might be
a bit harsh but it's just way I saw it
when you when am so who was the guy from
sky or whatever the face to face things
oh yeah yeah and you were saying you can
do it better right every [__] person
watches that no you can huh right you
don't need to say it but you're
justifying it to yourself and your eyes
I get frustrated because I've got this
chip on my shoulder like I've got a
place that I wanted how'd you get rid of
the chip because you're above that
already but you don't really like take
it from me mate you don't realize how
many how just how big this it you know
that chip thought I've realized in
talking to Dizzee Rascal I sort of seen
that in him as and I've noticed that in
a few successful people like it's it's
not attractive to look at when they were
a fan of someone and so like when so
when you look at a Gervase interview
just because obviously he's someone you
look up to and I [__] love the guy
you say he's happy in that he's proved
his point and he sort of content with
where he is in life whereas when you say
someone who's very very successful but
still a bit irritated about they should
be loved more or whatever here's it's
not a good
you know and like even like Eminem's
latest album a lot of people are like
he's just trying to over prove a point
that he's the greatest of all time when
most people still look at him as top ten
anyway so what you still trying to prove
sort of things and I guess I just need a
like let that go a little bit it's funny
to me that because it's some thousands
years ago people were still having the
same problems and I guess we sort of
feel that we were always progressing as
a human race but I you look at the same
problems we've got now um you know the
Romans the Greeks all their stories
needing the Bible all the stories are
about the same problems that we have now
hmm like about narcissism or not
realizing how good you really are or but
being trapped in a bubble not realizing
you know what the problem we've got or
you know being too arrogant or all these
things you'd have thought like would
have moved on yeah you know but we have
it it's ingrained and that's rather than
how many subscribers the Jesus have I
think exactly yeah and you know in
hundreds of years time people will be
leaving your YouTube videos in hotel
rooms you know I mean and funding that
they'll be crazy people on street
corners going untrue Geordie did say you
know if you don't [__] in the morning
and you don't get up you'll be a little
there'll be a little old woman on the
street corner with a speaker just doing
that yeah and they'll be called speaking
of it you and your girlfriend are very
cute
together you make a good couple I've got
a little sometimes you get a little
thing for a couple don't you like oh
yeah yeah ray at that yeah so [__]
funny you liked a picture of me and her
and I was just laid with her and I went
I swear Brian likes any picture that
you're on the scroll one rather than the
tile and I went through and any that was
just made yeah
I'll be like right wait let's say and
3000 others click on a boom Brian's the
top of every symbol yeah you don't mean
like in a in a funny way but it's just a
good-looking girl like it's a good
picture wait am i late
this couldn't but also you can tell
sometimes when a girl gives a guy a
certain kind of confidence mmm but then
it shows in just joining in look [__]
you look like there's a there's a vibe
though in the pictures as well like all
[__] aside level sexual - no no look
you look it's like I don't know if I'm
right in saying this but she saw it
gives you a bit of a oh yeah yeah she
grabbed you by the neck just know like
women God be honest here some women you
can say bring men down yeah I've seen
girlfriends like make men just you can
see this suck the [__] life of them
whereas other women they give men a lift
or something like in Swansea yeah maybe
I'm wrong maybe it's just a photograph
but that's what I get from she's yeah
she's absolutely spot-on she's someone
who at you you talk to her about
everything you know does she build you
are everything yeah everything so she'll
come home from work and I will just run
on and on and on and I'll tell you to
her so many sorry has to keep her and
she just loves here in it which is I'm
so grateful
like I convinced her whatever and she
constantly makes me a better person so I
will and all these these comments that I
get online that hurt because they're
true she's already said a hundred times
she's very [__] smart so so when I'm
doing a video I'll go before I upload it
she'll go she'll come and watch it and
she'll go you mention Katherine's before
internet and she's she's spot-on that
she said I need something like that -
naughty way know is the properties
online it can see the bits 19 list you
know if it's coming from a good place
so yeah cheers woman site so I just it's
got the same thing in his life
Alex yeah
yeah yeah yeah sure Sione was actually
really pissed off with me about the
whole well anything why you liked him
she knew that he'd been on my podcast
she doesn't like me falling out with
people needlessly yeah yeah and she and
she was you got our own Instagram so I
can go straight over a lot of people ask
that Brian and though she has a link to
the source media I just have to keep
what's up with the porn it takes a hell
of a lot no selfies don't do anymore
yeah they're definitely although I will
say the lines before the podcast I am
reaching a pipe with women where that
cell that seems like a good air
situation where you've got a girl who
watches all your videos and that and
loves you and and really takes an
interest that's that must be lovely yeah
real love you saying like that that
level where you you say things like it's
because it's kind of nice to for a long
time if I got a sour face on this
podcast you know you've looked a little
bit miserable and it's nice to him he
knows I'm joking
and then when you start talking about
here you sort of light up like this nice
about that and you go should make me a
better man you're gonna marry that girl
I could tell and good for you I reckon I
well I think it's a good idea so she
gets social media and realized there are
other men out there other options are
about the sheds loss
it's Fritzl stuff yeah we should both
take a media blackout don't you think
social media buy it'll be on me like a
rash yeah yeah we got that done my
advice any lads out there just for the
record find a woman who doesn't isn't a
project you're just happy with who she
is and someone who doesn't treat you
like a project yeah I'm finding that is
more and more like in my head from
experience with women in my life is like
you you meet a woman who either looks at
you as a fixer-upper or a potential good
guy or you're viewing them and you just
need to view them is who they are is
this the one are you compatible it
shouldn't be hard work all the time like
obviously kind of a little bit of work
or equate a relationships but like too
many people are like saw not compatible
in there like oh you've got to work on
it and you know that comment can
sometimes get misconstrued so in a
healthy relationship or a relationship
that maybe feels good in my experience
you put the hard work in to things that
then are rewarding it shouldn't be hard
work from a perspective of we're always
having an argument so problems as a real
thing yeah that's where the work comes
and you gotta compromise but I'm just
saying like yeah like things seem to be
going the way of like girls shouldn't be
looking at men as projects and that like
way well in a few years you'll be in who
I want to be and it's like no no like
that's saying that about you that could
really and low-level feels like it
undermines what someone's what you're
trying to be yeah it's basically going
at the moment you're half a man yeah
you're half the man that I'm that I'm
hoping you're one day the perfect
boyfriend's dick was muscle yeah yeah
which one which one yeah Wow it sort of
comes to a point nowhere and I guess
that there's a make-or-break point and
you guys have sort of got that make
point where Brian endorses the
relationship so yeah I'd love to be the
guy who marries you
oh maybe I've got to get ordained for
that but I'm well up for it I would love
to see that it's amazing the amount of
weddings that I've heard you try and
inject yourself into we've got the
bridesmaids Laurence and I said don't
make sure you think of anything worse to
do that imagine I've tried to pull a gun
at a Funeral once I pull and girls at
funerals yeah I love the fact that you
will basically stand at the front not
give a wishy-washy speech but you'll go
he's trying to [__] her permanently do
you yeah I do I do
[__] chaga that's gonna be the way
yeah it's weird though one last sale say
on the relationship thing last year was
very rocky and we have a lot of
arguments and we were almost broke up a
couple of times and that was very that
went hand-in-hand with where you were
where I was and me being a [__] online
and stuff like that and this year it's
been perfect there's not been one one
argument is do you think that that was
just cause you were in that place
because I'm in a better place
I wasn't me kind of yeah I thought I
think so well she saw you both sort of
lasted of course in a sense I want
you've been through that you get through
it and you know if you have to go
through the so there's apparently
there's three stages in a relationship
so they say which is the foreman where
you come together at the storming where
there's a little bit of a battle there
for where you fit in the relationship
and who's dominant or whatever where you
feel like you're places and then there's
the Norman where you come out at the end
and you are like a good couple hopefully
and in the back door man and then the
bucket when you get there Rome wings
after she's kosher just so you get
really tight both me just I knew that
was coming
no yeah oh yeah how long we been gone
for more than two hours we can finish on
a no yeah yeah sure all right that's our
we'll finish on anal as Chuck the party
prefers to yeah make sure you hit that
like button
I'll put chucks channel in the
description below I'll be being a
[__] good catch up mate let's been
great thanks javi I saw I've missed you
for quite a long time because you and I
we did that we were talking about them
we did the monopoly video thing oh yeah
and then once you taking my dish a while
so next so I've seen but the there being
a bit about the final squad it's
annoying me because I wanted them in the
to myself we'll get them in there before
showing run up on the pitch be awkward
there's no is no he's fit for boxing
trying to get you involved in a few
things and it's good to have you back
yes it's see Jack yeah here's Jack
subscribe thanks everyone we'll see you
there
cheers nice one fantastic podcast yeah